Salut ! Comme le mois dernier,
je vous fais un Vlog d'un seul coup !
C'est tout ce qui s'est passé
au mois de février,
enfin, quasiment tout parce que
parfois je n'ai pas la vidéo avec moi.
Il y a tout ce qui se passe
en tournée,
rarement ce qui se passait
à Paris
pourtant il s'est passé
quelques trucs cool
Par exemple, je suis allé chez
Carine Erseng et Victor Barange
vous savez, ceux qui ont fait
la F.A.Q. avec moi.
Ce sont des musiciens.
Même moi, je me suis essayé
à chanter avec eux, mon gars...
Attention : Malaise TV !
[Musique et chants]
C'est parti pour le Vlog
de février.
[Musique Générique]
Salut, on est le 3 février
c'est reparti pour le Vlog mensuel.
Il y a quelques jours,
j'ai mis le Vlog du mois de janvier
c'est plutôt bien accueilli,
je suis content.
Par contre, il y en a quelques un
d'entre vous qui ont trouvé que
c'était un petit peu trop long
20 minutes.
Je ne sais pas combien celui-là fera,
puisque c'est tout le mois... après on voit...
Mais si vous trouvez ça trop long,
ce que je peux comprendre ;
regardez le en plusieurs fois.
C'est aussi bête que ça !
Alors, je n'en mets qu'un
et puis vous pouvez le faire en plusieurs fois.
On est à Toulon,
au Room City.
Il fait noir.
Avec Garysaure.
Il est où Garysaure ?
Est-ce qu'il s'accouple comme
le Diablosaure ?
c.f. la vidéo du mois dernier.
On ne sait pas, hein...
Et alors, qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce mois-ci ?
Ben je vais vous dire
ce qui se passe...
Il se passe que, évidemment,
je vais repasser sur le livre, là,
je vais travailler à fond sur le premier jet
que j'ai sorti le mois dernier, en un mois.
On ne bâcle pas son travail.
Qu'est-ce que c'est joli
toutes ces lumières !
Le flash des projecteurs !
Du Zénith de Touloooon !
Du... Room City de Toulon...
Mais ça marche aussi...
Nous sommes le 4 janvier*
la représentation d'hier s'est
très bien passée,
merci d'être venus à Toulon
pour ceux qui étaient là.
Aujourd'hui, je joue 2 fois.
Avec peu d'écart entre les deux
représentations, du coup je ne sais pas
comment on va s'organiser
pour se voir...
Là, je suis logé dans un petit appartement
qui appartient au théâtre,
et, mon pote, il y a...
une inondation.
Donc, j'ai prévenu le propriétaire
du théâtre qu'il y a une inondation,
et qu'il fallait peut-être
la gérer...
Ce à quoi il m'a répondu :
"Il va falloir mettre du Destop,
c'est parce que tu dois avoir trop de cheveux."
Trop de cheveux ?
Trop de cheveux ?!
Alors, je veux bien avoir les cheveux épais
mais, déjà, ils ne sont pas très longs ;
On est quand même assez content
car depuis ma plus tendre enfance
mon front n'est pas trop
garni en terme de cheveux, donc
on est plutôt cool !
Je ne sais pas s'il se foutait de
ma gueule ou pas, du coup...
[Sur l'air de la chanson de Jacques Brel]
"Dans le port de Toulon...
y'a du vent et pas de café"
On veut du café. Gary !
[Gary] Ouais ?
[Fab] On veut du café.
Le Stade Rochelais, donc de La Rochelle
a gagné au rugby et euh...
et du coup, on essaye de se faire petits,
parce qu'on a gagné face à Toulon.
Tu vois ?
Ouais, on fait gaffe.
Philippe Roche doit nous rejoindre,
il ne va jamais savoir où on est.
Si vous me suivez sur Instagram
vous avez vu que je vais
monter une deuxième technique
pour devenir riche...
Toujours sur Gary.
Je crois que, pour en trouver une 3ème,
il va falloir que je me lève de bonne heure quand même.
Il commence à se méfier.
Philippe Roche vient de nous rejoindre
et il a laissé un peu de matos sur la table...
Du coup, on hésite :
Soit on lui prend un chèque,
on se fait un chèque...
et comme ça on divise
entre nous deux.
Et là ça commence à devenir intéressant.
Ou alors, je filme son numéro de carte bleue
et c'est plus pour les abonnés...
[Gary] Non, mais on va prendre le chèque
je pense.
[Fab] Ouaiiis. Ouais parce que vous
vous allez abuser.
On le sait, vous allez abuser.
Non, on va plutôt lui prendre un chèque.
On est le combien Garysaure ?
[Gary] On est le 5 !
Le 5 !
Février.
Ben oui. En même temps, il fallait
le faire pour avoir un doute sur le mois.
Je peux te dire qu'il fait un petit
temps des familles...
[On entend la pluie]
[Ironique] Oh là, là, le sud !
La beauté du sud !
[Gary] On a bien fait de venir, hein !?
[Fab] On nous avait dit : "Venez dans le sud,
il y a 150% de beau temps par an."
150% de jours de beau temps.
Je pense qu'on s'est un peu
foutu de notre geule...
Pour tous ceux qui croient que les artistes
dorment dans de luxueux hôtels.
Voici la réalité.
Un seul lit.
Un Garysaure, un Fabienzaure...
Cherche pas, t'as tort.
Découvrons les activités dominicales
d'un Garysaure.
Il m'a dit : "Je travaille".
[Gary] Sur ma carrière ! Tu vois,
je travaille pour ma carrière.
[Fab] Ah oui, c'est pour ta carrière...
C'est bien ça.
Allez ! On se prépare, on range les affaires
et c'est parti pour la 4ème Room City de Toulon.
On est dans les loges avec Garysaure,
juste avant de faire la dernière représentation
du Room City,
et alors, on s'est tapé un trip,
durant 4 jours avec Gary,
c'est par rapport à tous les systèmes
qui existent, tu sais, pour gagner de l'argent.
D'ailleurs, il y a une phrase pour ça,
il y a une phrase pour savoir quand est-ce
que tu vas te faire arnaquer, c'est :
[Gary] Assis-toi mon ami, tu vas gagner de l'argent.
Ça, ça c'est une bonne phrase
d'Arnakito.
On a décrété que c'étaient
des Arnakitos.
Du coup, on a monté 3 systèmes déjà...
en mode :
"Comment gagner de l'argent".
Je vous mets les vidéos.
Je les avais mises sur Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter
si vous ne me suivez pas : vous pouvez !
Il y a les liens dans la description,
je vous les mets. Peut-être qu'il y en aura
plus d'ici là, je vous les mettrai.
Mais là, c'est les 3 qu'on a faites.
On n'est pas peu fiers.
Avec ça...
Assis-toi mon ami. Tu vas gagner de l'argent.
Hé, Gary ! J'ai un bon plan pour toi,
pour gagner de l'argent :
Tu vas me filer 500 Euros
et on fait moitié, moitié
comme ça on a 250 balles chacun...
[Gary] Ok, ben je vais au distributeur.
Gary ! J'ai encore une meilleure
technique pour devenir riche :
tu vas retirer 500 Euros !
[Gary] 500, je ne peux pas.
400 je peux.
[Fab] Retire 400 et je mets 100 €
moi-même au bout.
Et là, on ne fait pas 50/50 mon gars !
On fait 60% pour toi et 40% pour moi.
C'est pas mal quand même...
[Gary] Ah ouais. Ben j'y vais.
[Gary] Tu veux que j'aille chercher un truc
à boire ? Tu veux un coca... ?
[Fab] Pas la peine,  c'est bon :
j'ai de l'eau.
Par contre, tu peux me donner l'équivalent
de ce que tu voulais m'offrir, en euros s'il-te-plaît ?
Du coup...
[Gary] Euh... ouais, attends...
[Fab] Tu vois...
Comme je ne le prends pas...
Aujourd'hui nous sommes le 7 !
Le 7, ça veut dire que je suis à Paris,
je suis rentré, hier,
hier soir je suis allé voir Barange
et Carine Erseng.
Vous vous souvenez ? On avait fait
l'ALFA-Q avec eux.
On a tapé le petit boeuf, hein.
Autant vous dire j'étais un peu ridicule...
Oh dis donc Michel.
Michel, il n'a plus de batterie.
Michel...
Plus de batterie...
Va falloir le charger.
Monsieur Philippe Roche,
quel jour sommes nous ?
[Phil] Et bien, nous sommes le samedi euh...
[Fab]11 !
[Phil] 11 !
[Fab] On est le 11 février,
on est à Paris, on est sur
la route de Versailles
et il y a toujours Philippe Roche
en fait, hein...
[Phil] Voilà. Sérieux...
[Fab] En fait le thème de Vlog de ce mois là
c'est Philippe Roche.
[Phil - riant] C'est Philippe...
[Fab] Il conduit avec son appli,
c'est incroyable, hein ?
Il est ouf ce Gary.
Bref. Hier on a fait la première
à Versailles,
ça s'est très bien passé.
Merci d'être venus.
Abonnez-vous, je rends.
[Accent "mafieux"] Mettez pouce bleu.
Et ce soir est un soir particulier
puisque, à Lille il y a SuperKonar
qui était venu me voir jouer
et là il y a Top10 qui vient ce soir.
C'est cool !
Taupe10, le petit mytho...
Taupe10, alias Arnaquito...
Cette grosse arnaque.
C'est tellement gros que, il y en a, encore,
dans les commentaires,
qui pensent que l'explication de l'arnaque
est, elle-même, une arnaque...
On va loin dans le complot.
Tu vois : il y a le complot.
Et il y a le complot des reptiliens, tu vois ?
[Musique de X-Files]
Si j'avais mes deux mains libres
je ferai le symbole des illuminati,
mais là, il faut que tu l'imagines...
Illuminati...
Comme la plupart des théâtres
et des café-théâtres,
on est dans une cave.
On est en bas.
J'ai joué là durant 6 mois,
tous les vendredis.
C'était en 2012 ?
C'était en quelle année ?
[Homme] 2012.
[Fab] 2012 !
[Homme] 2012 et... c'était super !
[H] T'as fait... Ouais, t'as fait 3 mois.
[Fab] Je jouais ici. Ici, là.
Et on mettait le public par là...
[H] Voilà. Quand les gens n'étaient pas contents,
ils sortaient par la sortie de secours.
[Fab] Et ouais. Et ça sortait souvent, hein...
[Rires]
[Fab] C'était terrible.
[Fab] Oh un Philippe Roche !
[Phil] D'ailleurs : les loges de Philippe Roche...
[Fab] Tu me fais vraiment le running-gag de...
[Phil] C'est vrai.
[Fab] de ce Vlog du mois de février.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe, quelques secondes
avant le spectacle ?
Je suis là, je suis en train de stresser,
je m'habille, etc...
Et puis, après, je prends cette
petite route là.
Là, je passe par là.
Hop.
Ici, c'est noir salle.
Là, vous vous êtes juste là.
Moi je fais un petit pas...
un petit pas d'élan, comme ceci.
Hop ! Un petit pas d'élan.
Pour me faufiler là.
Marcher sur les marche où mon Garysaure
me met de jolies traces blanches,
sinon je me pète la gueule dans le noir,
et on ne rigole pas.
Et après, j'arrive sur scène,
juste par là !
Et je fais :
"Salut la Royale Factory !!!"
Vous avez vu comment il est
joli ce lieu ?
Si vous êtes un jour de passage là,
c'est à Versailles,
ça s'appelle la Royale Factory.
Je suis vraiment amoureux
de ce théâtre.
C'est une création à 100%
Ils ont fait un lieu... Regarde les lustres là,
tous les sièges et tout ça...
[Avec un accent]
C'est magnifique !
C'est très joli.
Han ! Mais qui arrive ?
Ben Philippe Roche...
[Phil] Donc là, on est à côté de cette
magnifique scène où...
où on se bat pour mon micro !
Philippe Roche est quelqu'un
d'important...
[Technicien] Ah ouais, mais attends, il faut qu'on
passe le câble. S'il va à cour, euh...
[Fab - au technicien] En fait, est-ce que tu es en train de
dire que le mec qui fait la 1ère partie, nous fait chier ?
[Rires]
Alors Fabien... désolé, c'est vrai que
je suis souvent avec toi,
mais c'est pour une bonne raison,
c'est parce qu'en fait tu adores l'imitation !
Tu es un super bon imitateur !
C'est vrais que, sorti de Krazuki ou encore
nos anciens présidents :
[Imitant Giscard d'Estaing]
Monsieur bônsoir.
T'as pas grand chose.
Mais... mais quand même...
Ah si ! Vous lui demandez de faire
Simon et Pumba aussi...
Demandez lui ces petits défis, comme çà,
d'imitation. Il est... très très fort.
Faites le aussi, quoi.
Parce que...
Ben parce que c'est seul en fait
un artiste, hein.
Même si vous êtes nombreux
à le suivre,
ben dans les galas, les hôtels,
et voilà, les loges comme ça,
on se retrouve souvent tout seul,
face à soit même.
Donc euh...
Donc, ben voilà, je suis son... son imitateur
sa petite lumière de la tournée,
son... son rossignol !
Bon. Euh...
Bon, en attendant, le rossignol va
aller sur scène.
Parce que, moi aussi j'ai le droit
de répéter !
[Chant d'opéra]
[Applaudissements d'une personne]
[Fab] Hé ! Vous avez vu ?
Le travail de ce mec, c'est énorme !
Arriver à faire çà !
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Les heures de boulot pour que les lèvres
soient pile-poil en même temps que la bande son...
C'est incroyable !
[Fab] Le play-back de ouf.
[Phil] Qu'est-ce que je te disais...
[Phil] C'est...
[Fab] Le play-back au top !!
[Fab] C'est le plus beau play-back de France
ce mec !!
[Phil] Voilà. Je passe ma vie à me faire
vanner par ce mec là...
Bon,  ben on est plutôt pas mal... ?
[Tech] Ben franchement ouais !
Qu'est-ce que t'en penses toi ?
[Phil] Ben écoutez...
[Fabien - riant] La bonne phrase !
[Fab] Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Tu vois, je trouve que c'est de la merde !
[Phil] Réponse de la régie :
"Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?"
Qu'est-ce que tu disais, il y a 2 secondes,
sur ma voix quand tu faisais les réglages ?
[Tech] Je disais que c'était compliqué de trouver
un bon réglage pour toi,
parce que t'es vraiment compliqué
à régler, quoi...
[Rires & applaudissements]
[Phil] Voilà. On appelle ça :
les mecs mentalisés...
[Tech] ... que tu as une belle voix et
qu'il n'y avait pas grand chose à jeter dedans.
[Fab] Ça veut dire qu'il y en a un peu !
[Phil] Ça veut dire qu'il y a quand même du déchet...
[Rires]
[Phil] Voilà...                                 Bon...
[Tech] Ouais, mais la perfection n'existe pas...
[Phil] Ouais, bien sûr...
[Fab] Ben on avait remarqué, hein...
Depuis que tu nous fais la régie...
[Rires]
Nous sommes le 16 février.
Je viens d'arriver à Grenoble,
au théâtre de la Bassecour
où je suis venu jouer ici
en 2015 !
Et ici je suis avec Diablosaure !
[Diablo - Tests son] Hi, hi, ha, ha ,haaa.
[Fab] Diablosaure, si je t'attrape...
[Diablo] Voilà, voilà.  ohaaaaa ! J'te mords !
Euh... résumé des épisodes précédents :
Je suis en train de repasser sur le livre,
ça, toujours...
J'avance bien sur le jeu menteur-menteur,
j'espère que... euh... ça va vous plaire.
Haannn ! Par contre, je parle très très mal
parce que je suis malade.
J'ai rendez-vous chez
S.O.S. Médecin.
Non ! Pas chez S.O.S. Médecins !
[Phil] Médecin 7/7
[Fab] Chez Médecin 7/7, parce que
S.O.S. Médecin, ils m'ont dit, grosso-modo :
"Ça nous intéresse pas trop, trop, trop..."
[Rires de Philippe]
"Venez dans une autre ville."
[Diablo fait des essais son]
[Fab] Mais vraiment !
Donc j'ai rendez-vous dans 50 minutes
chez le médecin.
[Diablo - Tests son] Voilà, voilà, voilà...
[Fab] Et voilà.
[Diablo - Tests "chantés"] Voilà, voilà, voilà
[Fab] Là, ça va être un petit peu chaud,
[Diablo - chantant] voilà, voilà, voilà.
[Fab] j'ai les petites suées.
[Fab] Oh ! Tu peux te taire !?
[Diablo] Aooooo !!!
[Fab] Moi, je parle avec 400.000 personnes !
[Petits cris de Diablosaure]
Il ne se rend pas compte.
Il a une télévision où il a
5 chaînes dessus.
Dont une cryptée.
[Bruits de bouche de Diablosaure]
Celle qu'il regarde le plus...
Là, par exemple, il croit
que je téléphone.
[Rires moqueurs]
On le voit qu'il n'est pas net...
[Diablo] Blblblblblbl, oui, ne quittez pas.
[Diablo - Voix de perroquet] Rrrrrrr, coco !
Ce n'est pas facile la tournée.
Donc, en attendant le médecin, ça me laisse
quand même le temps de m'installer sur le plateau.
Alors c'est parti...
[Musique rapide]
Hé ! C'est pas fini, hein !?
C'est que j'étais en train de réviser Pi.
Et "Pi" c'est tout !
Nous sommes, aujourd'hui,
Monsieur Greg Delelo ?
Delélo ?
[Chanté] Delélo...
On est quel jour ?
[Greg] Vendredi !
[Fab] Vendrediiii !
Évidemment !
Je vous présente Greg.
C'est lui qui a inspiré le personnage
de Grincheux.
Mais sans son bonnet,
ça se voit moins.
Il est donc 20h44 et je ne suis pas
encore changé, mais pourquoi ?!
Mais parce que j'ai quelqu'un
qui vient dans les loges !
C'est Monsieur Youtunes !
[You] Wesh ! Comme on dit...
chez les jeunes.
[Fab] Et en fait, les gens attendent de toi
que tu fasses de la musique là.
[You - voix aigüe et fausse] Tu lu tu lu lu !
[You] Moment gênant !
Malaise TV !
C'est très bluffant, c'est extrêmement bluffant,
ce mec, comme ça, tout le temps il peut
faire tut tut tut avec sa...
[Fab] C'est dingue.
[You] C'est quelque chose qui m'arrive
un peu tous les jours.
Abonnez vous, il rend.
[Enroué] Vous vous souvenez,
dans le Vlog du mois dernier,
j'avais une voix un peu grave
et toujours rauque parce que j'étais malade.
Hé bé, voilà !
C'est reparti...
On entend que m'a voix se barre un peu
dans les aigus, elle fait ce qu'elle veut...
C'est ouf...
C'est terrible.
Le pire c'est que, cet après midi,
je voulais faire plein, plein de choses ;
j'ai sorti la vidéo de ce matin
et tout...
Et je me suis rendormi
tout l'après midi, quoi.
Euh... genre, le corps me dit stop.
C'est terminé Fabien.
Et c'est donc la dernière soirée de cette
première semaine à la Bassecour à Grenoble
et je vais rejoindre mon
Diablosaure...
[Bruit ambiance Café]
[Fab - Voix rauque] Diablo...
[Fab - Criant] De retour au théâtre de la Bassecour
à Grenoble quel jour sommes nous Diablosaure !!!?
[Greg] Euh... Vingt.... Euh.... Cinq ?
Non.
Euh... 25....24.... 23 !
[Musique]
[Bruit d'un petit objet tombant sur la parquet]
[Diablo pousse un cri]
Salut, j'ai la pression pour le livre,
je suis en train de revoir plein de chapitres,
Il faut que je le rende dimanche,
dernier carat.
Mais j'ai grave de choses à faire
cette semaine.
C'est à dire que là, il faut que je retourne au théâtre pour
faire la mise en place et pour faire le spectacle ;
et ouiii...
Demain matin je vais un Escape Game avec
Jordan, Youtunes, et puis Diablosaure,
ça va être drôle.
L'après-midi, je fais une vidéo
que vous aurez déjà vue entre-temps
avec As2piK.
J'ai trouvé aussi une nouvelle méthode
pour gagner de l'arget :
"Arnakito, volume 4"
Si vous me suivez sur Snap ou Twitter ou Insta,
même Facebook je crois que je l'ai mis,
je l'ai mis partout celui-là
tellement il me faisait rire ;
vous l'avez vu passer, sinon je vais
vous le remettre là.
Et si vous ne me suivez pas sur
les réseaux sociaux,
vous pouvez me rejoindre !
Je suis au taquet  dessus, j'adore ça.
Et vous avez tous les liens
dans la description.
Il y a toujours tout dans
la description...
Mon Diablo, j'ai un bon plan pour toi :
je te parie 10€ que tu me donnes 20€ et que
j'arrive à t'en rendre 40 !
Je te parie çà.
[Diablo] Ouais ! Euh... 20€... 40€... Génial !
[Fab] Hé ! C'est pas mal !
[Fab]Et je te parie 10 balles que j'y arrive.
Ça marche ?
[Diablo] Génial, génial ! Tiens !
[Diablo] Je te donne 20€,
tu me donnes 40€.
[Fab] 10€ et 20€. Tu vois, je t'ai parié
10 balles que je t'en rendrai 40...
[Diablo] C'est génial !
[Fab] Et bé, tu sais quoi ?
J'ai été un peu présomptueux,
je crois que j'ai râté mon pari.
Du coup, je te rends 10.
Parce que je tiens à payer
mes dettes.
[Diablo bafouille d'incompréhension]
[Fab] Ben, je t'avais parié 10€ que je t'en
rendrai 40. Je n'ai pas réussi à t'en rendre 40,
et bé je paye mes dettes,
je paye les 10€.
[Diablo] Je me suis fais avoir là !
[Fab] C'est ça.
Et nous sommes maintenant le 28 février,
je peux le prouver.
Grâce à ce petit calendrier digital.
Depuis le mois d'octobre, vous avez vu
des vidéos, dans ce bureau qui était complètement vide,
et, au fur et à mesure,
vous avez vu des choses arriver.
Et bien là, il est terminé !
Enfin... je pense qu'il est terminé quoi...
Et si vous voulez, je vous fais une petite visite
en une minute des familles...
Si un jour vous venez au bureau,
vous allez entrer par ici.
et vous allez tomber sur :
çà !
Ça c'est mon ancien rétro-projecteur
que j'ai amené au bureau, du coup.
pour afficher sur ce mur !
Le petit canapé parfait. Canapé qui m'a été offert
par CDiscount, comme pas mal de choses en fait ici,
je voudrais vraiment les remercier,
et je vous mets un lien dans la description
si vous aussi vous voulez des trucs
d'aménagement.
En fait, j'avais déjà passé un commande chez eux
pour pas mal de choses,
et, sur la commande d'après, ils m'ont contacté pour me proposer de m'aider à meubler le bureau,
Merci, c'est énorme !
Et ça, c'est très sympatique.
On apprécie beaucoup.
Donc, si on continue :
Hop ! Les petites étagères, euh...
qui vont bien.
Oh ! Ça c'est mon boulier !
Le petit meuble avec le Mano Solo
que j'avais dessiné chez mon pote Zapata.
Bien sûr, la lumière ne reste pas là
en permanence...
Le bureau...
Le fameux trophée des 100.000...
Le fameux trophée des 100.000
[Rires]
Vous là, qui regardez la vidéo,
vous êtes là-dedans !
Vous faites partie, en fait...
Je vous ai rangés dans une boîte il y a longtemps.
Et je vous garde près de moi.
Çà c'est si vous voulez me voir
également sur scène.
C'est un spectacle d'humour !
Mais qui parle de mentalisme.
Durant plus d'une heure et demi.
Ce mois-ci je serai : à Lyon, à Narbone,
à Bordeaux, à Valence, à Toulouse, à Montauban
et après, il y a encore plein d'autres villes
les autres mois ;
Vous avez un lien vers les dates de spectacle
dans la description.
Si, à un moment donné, vous avez besoin
de vous isoler :
il y a des toilettes...
Et enfin, ce qu'on appelle communément
un débarras.
Michel, Micheline, toujours près à partir
au combat.
Çà, çà a été dit.
Ça me fait penser que je ne vous ai
pas présenté Ibra.
Je vous le présenterai tout à l'heure.
Alors ça, c'est Ibra !
[Avec un accent]
Et Ibra il fait quoi ? Il laisse pas un pouce bleu,
non ! Il détruit !
[Le broyeur se met en marche]
[Le bruit du broyeur est très présent]
Je donne des noms à mes objets.
Parce que oui ! Parfois !
Dans un bureau. On se sent seul !
Un truc que je ne vous ai pas dit c'est que
depuis le mois de janvier,
on est complet à toutes les dates du spectacle
partout où on passe en tournée.
C'est génial. Merci. C'est un vrai kiffe de
vous voir, à chaque fois, à la fin, on prend du temps
C'est cool.
Le 18 mai, je vous le dis ici :
parce que, assez peu de personnes
iront au bout de cette vidéo,
[à part les sous-titreurs ;-) ]
Il y a mon livre qui sort.
qui va s'appeler :
" Votre cerveau est extraordinaire "
J'espère qu'il vous plaira.
C'était très bizarre là, d'envoyer toutes
les dernières corrections
à l'éditeur en me disant que maintenant
je ne peux plus rien toucher en fait.
Et puis, si cette vidéo vous a plu,
vous pouvez la liker, c'est important.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner
à la chaîne, si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Et rendez-vous très bientôt.
Ciao.
[Musique générique de fin]